half gone bris - poor Deepak welcome
back to another episode of alien
isolation
I feel Lysa later all right one of those
robots with it weird Chin's just kill
that man
and I'm like why he was nice just shot
you in the knee but can't you see I want
to shoot you in the knee while you pee
[ __ ] or better what Oh got it
we better not let them see us let's
investigate this man perhaps he had a
key card on him yeah oh we need that
excelencia now we can craft some [ __ ]
how puts how are you doing shut up shut
your [ __ ] mouth so mean what oh we need
a compound be my bein my I always mix up
the compound B with the injectors
classic pills Wow some some scotch
called ethanol welding chemistry it's
actually called shut up bad path shut up
folder Crafton utility no well this is
before Facebook remember that kids not
everything was good I mean this was when
he was kid what is he doing you [ __ ]
creeps me out man should I kill him what
should I do
let's just Oh God oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh God he knows we're here
can we turn this off huh okay that's
good now we can pass all right think
we're good
oh man hahaha I need to check my you
porn account Oh God
[ __ ] me with the sounds I hate it I
absolutely hate it oh there's something
there
you gotta get that boom boom boom who
are they talking to he must be crazy I
think you're crazy laughing Jack Ray's a
now we can go here what is that sound
I don't trust those for one second comms
control comes control to major Chum come
on bring it on Britney oh God oh it's so
slow ah they really have tension oh
there we go there we go go
later noobs [ __ ] my ass out man this
game is so immersive it's been a while
since I played this game a game so I say
oh that's not good
that's our captain no wonder people
don't reply the [ __ ] robots are
taking over and say we go this route I
don't really trust this tracker though
it doesn't seem to be doing this justice
it's used to track bugs no axes huh
can't damn a with today here we go
there's someone here right does it seem
like it oh god what'd I just do oh let's
disable the camera
there we go I don't like that I don't
like that they have a camera there we go
why it's still looking at me I don't
like this here we go that's just great
[ __ ] gotta be someone the station I can
contact I've got a hack into this it's
very interesting this thing there we go
that's how you hack remember kids yeah
we're one a hack that's how you do it
Saba stole a link my favorite link in
the entire word torrents weyland-yutani
bond and so ID we said before this is
the lane on the torrents what the hell
just happened the best of all did any of
our ABAP makers board please respond
take it damn it looks like we're the
only one space systems will be down
while we repair I can't say for how long
all right let's go into hole Shh ah what
what the hell is your problem
don't touch me your pizza butter butter
butter butter butter full of butter of
berapa papa
Oh God oh god are they coming you white
son of a [ __ ] I can say that without
being racist son of a sniper alright or
thought I [ __ ] up Oh [ __ ] must think
I'm a [ __ ] dummy oh oh oh I'll
be going out I'll be going so great to
see you
oh [ __ ] they're so badass [ __ ] uh I'm
just gonna give gum coming home coming
home tell the word that I'm coming home
yes see me now right uh oh yeah that
revolver really did the trick
Jesus Christ Oh God
Jesus what an ass what a complete and
[ __ ] utter ass you are
piece of [ __ ] bold - not that there's
anything wrong with that
how did he find me well this is chilling
relaxing max Oh a new blueprint Oh same
station hey I'd allow myself a Shan it's
been forever sometimes they come every
corner oh I hear him all right it's here
somewhere
there it is uh what the [ __ ] is this
well I don't know balance the values you
[ __ ] high
did I do it
okay Oh God this is so [ __ ] creepy
press matching move keys okay I got it
no there we go did it
this is really [ __ ] atmospheric man
move keys to highlight values until you
confirm okay um what the [ __ ] it's so
fast
did it with that it bros Wow you're
alive it's rippling friendly Taylor hit
swiftly we were getting worried we made
it oh really
you were the transit station now it's
right by medical okay Mattie call
Samuels listen to me it's that shape she
seeks ins got the shui shocked I'm their
goddamn androids are killing people
that's impossible it's country two
primary synthetic program seen it Samuel
I guess seeks ins got a different idea
about synthetics and there's something
else here a creature it's big and it's
lethal Ripley slow down creature yes
form an unknown type some kind of alien
organism it's extremely dangerous you
and Taylor Idina Kayla it hurt she was
injured by debris during the crossing
[ __ ] how bad I can't move her I need
medical supplies we need to treat and
pack the insurance the radio is broken I
can't contact the lane we're on our own
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay I'll come to you keep
your eyes open Oh Thunder come to
Claudia
at rancid karma that would be wonderful
Oh
that's not very good is it same station
got a llama save sanction thank you then
it sync to my [ __ ] dummy why
are we going then return wait what what
uh what you cereal he was serious what
the [ __ ] Bartol time I'm swimming around
in a vagina I'm not playing games it's
not a game at all why do you talk about
I'm swimming around and everything don't
trust anything IO no trans trust Otto
Naruto Naruto [ __ ] where do we need to
go there we need to go there
Oh God look how far it is sick to my
mother [ __ ] dummy [ __ ] my stink I
don't like this press I don't like this
one bit and by one bit I don't mean
nothing oh no no no no no no no no
okay we can go through here there's
nothing here though Oh another Jesus
that's creepy man that's really [ __ ]
creepy oh it tracks them I will get this
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go Go Go just [ __ ] Yossef up
[ __ ]
save station [ __ ] Oh God
come on return alright alright alright
let's go in here we did it we did a
press that's gonna be amazing I love it
all other keyboards they have in the
future it's like warranty [ __ ] that
this is squirty or qui fee
we only see me alien twice one time in a
cutscene Oh God not to [ __ ] again
what dare alright are we going there
there return through [ __ ] thank you
hi wha
I was always been a big fan of returning
through [ __ ] all right we better go
in the back home go in the back hole
they said it would be fun and exciting
they said don't do anything you regret
that's the guy that was killed
ahh what are we alright this is perfect
oh we can't or can't we come on you can
do it girl
that probably didn't make a noise at all
oh he's right [ __ ] there
okay okay yeah I don't really want to
take this route never really asked for
this you know you can hear the alien
walk above us
that's what's so [ __ ] terrifying I
come from oh oh now he's coming [ __ ]
please you don't see [ __ ]
all right we're good
what's with the sound oh I'm not a big
fan of this sound that was too close
how are we gonna get past him
this is ridiculous if that [ __ ] work
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope AJ
not work [ __ ] you
let's go Oh God
go go go go go we're cool we're cooler
than kaput if I get it now
well me neither honestly that
suppressing something about stealth that
just makes everything so harsh
all right sorry here we are in the lobby
he should be here this guy's over back
here oh god no no what the [ __ ] oh no no
no no no no no no no no it's not what I
think it is he's in here isn't he
what is that it's moving fast as [ __ ]
did you see that alright alright easy
stop doing that - brainy flagon [ __ ]
huh please II think I'm doing I'm gonna
be the next Top Model
listen to me oh my god carefully I want
you to leave work now I'd like to Claire
pick up the cat and head home
forget the cat need to find someplace
safe till seek some sin - Evan I saw the
guy from down the hall yeah can't
remember his name the one in the dirty
baseball cap weird smell he had
something in his coat what's it was a
gun you just looked right through me
don't talk to anyone don't tell the way
you're going
I'll meet you as soon as I can
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I think it's right [ __ ] here
oh my god you can hear that son of a
[ __ ] alright we're back here oh my god
safe station safe station got allowed
myself station ah what did we get
transmitted to scheme tower uh-oh
okay that's hard we going what's going
on this game displace with my emotion
like a [ __ ] woman I don't even know
bring it on Brittany oh [ __ ]
Oh Taylor Ripley is it
Ripley yep that's me what did you guys
do how did you guys survive how is she
she needs treatment
Medical is nearby I didn't want to leave
that we're gonna investigate see what I
can find you stay with her I'll try to
repair the radio booster
what if this creature shows up well you
straight up de dead Oh God
nice is what I love to hear safety is
important give me a [ __ ] break
San Cristobal medicals facilities there
we please finding help yeah sure
all right open please [ __ ] creeper
face minecraft B what's with a piece man
what does it mean how long Tower Link
transit that's my favorite so chic tres
chic Oh
locked where there oh god there's more
of those [ __ ] seriously thought we
were cool with us by now oh god oh god
oh god they're all opening why
what is up with that
well that's pretty you can never trust
yes please I need a doctor
hello I needed nice going out here why
does he trust me that could be a
murderer
what the [ __ ] alright well I'll take it
I don't understand everyone was so it
like keep it to itself but this guy is
like an angel
I ship us yes I ship it I ship it on the
spaceship that's how hard we're shipping
it all right well this is been a
pleasure well wish vent
there we go I wouldn't call these vents
I would just call them extra school I
don't have a chest this oh god don't
like this
just to be safe I'm never safe in
anything in my tire light just wanna get
off this place they should take Space
Station where are we
space barrels what are you doing good in
life I don't like you watch looking at
me right what is this
should I be scared when it's barbra
streisand doing here
[ __ ] oh yes
Ripley I need to find a doctor my friend
needs help medical supplies there are no
supplies on this
Hospital dispensary yeah yeah we get
their beauty mine you find the passcode
for the service elevator and then I'll
come down to the hospital with you okay
ask him
yeah I can direct you from here holy lip
God would have had the view passcode yay
I was just hoping for him to say some
[ __ ] like that
more lease office who the [ __ ] is
morally the wonder he ever here this is
say aqui
are you are saying station howl am
myself say check did it bit stick to my
[ __ ] tummy but you must think
I'm a [ __ ] dummy because I just
wanted a snake I'm broke
[ __ ] anyone Roach yeah I made a lot of
money
you should pay fit you're very clever
nine men must tell me where to go crime
uh Southie
some people can't adapt to it that's
awesome yeah I almost feel so weird
don't take kindly to be left
mm I use the dispensary today in fact I
was locked out I can't possibly be
expected to carry out my duties lingard
cut my access privileges
perhaps not wonderful are so precarious
Jesus Christ these guys love to talk
yeah how do I get in this light can't
damn it
ah which one should we go in
invalid all this one then I spent in the
been a while mate if you go wonderful
I have such pretty fingers I can really
appreciate being a girl in this game I
um buy the computer
semi stole the link everyone has the
same computer I love it
no leave it the audio nope
no such file thanks uh one 7:02 yep yeah
Morley's are you morally what do you do
hates dangling a shake I'm uh uh is
you're telling me died or was I
well it's not picking up anything so I
guess we're okay for now working
Morrison B I'm gonna call him Morrison I
know they might not be correct but where
is he jump bloody feet down spotlit oh
god oh god oh god no nope nope nope I am
out of here man oh God
and begins and begins ah where is it
heading over there faint a stick we
can't even fight against [ __ ] bold
men how are we gonna I just want to go
home
what is he doing here uh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no okay that
was probably just a scripted event right
yeah it's going away see we're fine this
is a scripted event I think I'm scared
I never you to restore power [ __ ] where
is that [ __ ]
Oh God [ __ ] me in the ass all the side
oh god oh god I got to go oh
Jesus Christ wait what is he doing but
I'll start doing
Oh God Oh God
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
does it say where he is Oh Darius okay
okay okay
but we can do this I'm a man men have
feelings too
that doesn't mean we can't be scared
[ __ ] I wish we had power right now oh
god oh god
uh-oh
oh my god that's it brofist